how you doing I'm Antoine Bethea and
this is stark [ __ ] and cut all right
I must I'm gonna start Remember the
Titans I'm a bench Rudy and I'm cut
Friday Night Lights night I'm a couple
Friday Night Lights man other two major
two classics man just two classes so
he's just our man up i'ma start the
blueprint obviously jay-z one of my my
top three favorite artists I'm a [ __ ]
get rich or die trying
that's a hard pitching he's definitely
my sixth man coming off the bench 50
kilter with that I remember where I was
that during that time and I'm gonna have
to cut the call two three
it sucks to say that but again man out
of those three man out without that's
that's what I got to get out of there
I'm I'm definitely gonna start the wings
you can't have a Super Bowl party
without the wings I'm definitely gonna
cut the dip definitely with the wicker
with the crowd somebody's gonna be
double dipping and that's definitely a
no-no okay I must I'm gonna start Serena
Williams just think as a black female
what she's done for that sport it's
unheard of
I'm a bench top it was obviously you
know what he's done for the game of golf
you could just see like when he's out of
the game what girlfriends and when he's
in the you know what will heat when he
is playing what he does for that game
and you know Tom Brady is a goatman you
know I just gotta cut him
I'm cutting the buggy I'm gonna start
the moonwalk you know I think everybody
some point in life had a socks on on the
kitchen floor trying to moonwalk and I'm
a [ __ ] Circosta you know I think
everybody you know want to get their
Carson that Carson moves in yeah fast
now this is low it's just not me not my
flavor not my style